governor sysolak announcing today he is
easing covet 19 restrictions on some
youth
sports in the valley families very
excited to get back to games adding that
a world without sports
has not been easy sasha loftis joining
us live near durango and desert inn
with more on what some kids are doing to
play sports again safely
well ryan so many were thrilled to hear
that announcement today but many
parents coaches and players tell me it's
been a tough few months
they say they found new and safe ways to
stay
mentally and physically fit until all
sports get the all clear
people don't realize how important these
activities are for the youth
after months of kovid closures it's time
for
some kids in the valley to get back in
the game
this new directive will allow
recreational sports practice
training and play for specified
non-contact and minimal contact sports
while it's great to see sports like
soccer and baseball resume under
governor sissellach's latest
announcement
many say the pause has put a strain on
kids
and families alike you feel empty you
know like you can't
go out and do like your regular routine
that's why
they're safely keeping their skills
sharp at conditioning gyms like this
we were getting calls every day about
parents being concerned about the kids
being able to
to get out the house to get some
exercise in parents call
friday's update a step in the right
direction
and until everyone gets the all clear
teens will keep working
towards a total rebound we want the best
for our children of course
and and just keeping them in captivity
in the house isn't always the best thing
that way they're mentally and physically
ready
for whatever comes next i think it'll
make it better because the kids will
appreciate
what they missed now
now here's a breakdown of that new
directive which takes place here comes
into place rather in about an hour at
1201 a.m
minimal or no contact sports are allowed
to resume
games competitions and tournaments this
includes
baseball softball volleyball golf tennis
and
others before any competition can begin
though a sports coveted 19 preparedness
and safety plan must be submitted
and approved by the state the same goes
for tournaments which cannot resume
until october 24th now we of course have
a look at that entire directive and
all the different guidelines you have to
follow things like that that is on our
website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now